okay so good morning um today we start
the Vikings we will do it over two
classes um and the Vikings are extremely
interesting and I believe that they are
one of the most underappreciated and un
and misunderstood European cultures in
the westan tradition uh there are two
main pillars the Greco Romans and the
judeo Christians
um the four traditions uh the Greeks the
Romans the Jews the Christians um have
been over studied uh and over
appreciated I would argue that the
Vikings are very important and should be
part of these four pillars I think there
should be five pillars and I think um
that over the next few decades people
will Scholars will slowly reveal to us
the importance of Viking culture to to
development of Western Civilization so
that's my argument to you over the next
two classes that the Vikings are uh
extremely
influential and um so today I'll do an
overview of Viking history and influence
and the next class I'll focus more on
the cultural system of the Vikings what
they
believed um and how they understood the
world okay so let's do a brief
historical overview so the Viking age is
what Scholars term the period from the
year 793 to 1066 79
793 is uh when there was the first
recorded written down um incident of a
Viking raid on a monastery in Europe and
this is really the first uh one of the
first written records of the Vikings the
Vikings were always there actually and
there was some interaction between U the
Vikings and the rest of Europe for
example Vikings did serve as mercenaries
in the Roman Empire okay so there was
always a bit of interaction but um for
the most part um the Vikings were an
isolated culture 1066 the year that the
Viking age is supposedly to have ended
is a year of the Battle of Hastings that
is when um Normandy the Normans um who
lived in France they crossed English
Channel and conquered England and this
is the last time that uh England would
be
conquered and this would Mark the end of
the Viking age because it really marked
the assimilation or integration of
Viking culture into the broader European
framework okay so that's what Scholars
mean by the Viking
age all right so the the Vikings um are
from the three countries today we call
Denmark Norway and Sweden okay
collectively they are known as the
Scandinavian uh
countries what's interesting about this
area is the geography this is a top
topography okay red means High attitude
high altitude blue means low altitude so
by the Sea and as you can see from the
topography
um the scan area is extremely diverse
and as a result um the region
historically has been very poor
isolated um and diverse okay so uh so
this area for the longest time had geres
diversity in terms of culture and
politics you had Kings you had tribal
Chieftain and then you had
um different systems as as well
okay um during the Viking age what we
need to keep in mind is this was a
period in history when Europe was being
invaded or attacked or pillaged from
everyone basically okay so the three
main Invaders are the Vikings who come
in from the north but then you have
people call the mag yards
who are the modern name hungarians
coming in from the east from the south
comes the Arabs okay next week we will
do the Arabs the mards uh just just that
you know who the mag yards are they are
just the most recent iteration of the
Proto indo-europeans they have NAA
remember uh last semester we discussed
that 3 to 4,000 years ago Old Europe who
are mainly um who are which was mainly
in Agricultural Society they were
eventually invaded and conquered by the
Proto Indo Europeans the yah who lived
in the steps uh these are pastoral
nomads and as a as a result they brought
their culture to them so the mards are
just the most recent uh iteration of
this culture okay same as the Hunts same
as the gos same as the jtic
people um what's interesting about the
mag yards is that they are mainly a land
people mean they ride horses into battle
and for and during the Viking age they
were extremely successful pen
penetrating into many parts of Europe
before they are eventually defeated and
they're integrated into the M the main
European culture mainly by you guys
remember making into Christians right
that that's how you assimilate people in
Europe by turning them into Christians
and because um uh this is the Western
Europe a lot of them become Catholic but
some also become um Orthodox as
well the Vikings are a very different
culture because they attack Europe not
by land not with Cavalry and horses but
by sea and rivers okay this is a
um Maritime
people and what's really interesting
about the Vikings is how far they extend
across uh the world okay so the first um
the first sort of encounter is when the
Vikings start to raid and
pillage um Europe okay Northern and
Central Europe but over time what they
will do is they will
extend over to the east as well where
they will found two major settlements
the first is ke Kei uh in modern day
Ukraine as well as novag grad okay so
they are going going into the dener as
well as the vocal why are they here um
there's some pillaging but mainly it's
for trade purposes because if you look
at where they are in KF and novad it it
gives them access to three major cental
of global wealth the first of course is
the b b Empire in conop which we um
studied then there is something called
the Abbasid califit which is the Islamic
empire in Baghdad and the third of
course is the Silk Road right which
gives them access to China so in other
words the Vikings encountered every
major culture in the world at this time
through their trade routes
and then what they will also do is go
west to found colonies they will make
settlements in Iceland in Greenland and
in modern day uh Canada uh the
settlement is called vinand uh and it's
in modern day New Foundland
okay so Iceland is still with us today
and Iceland is very interesting in uh
for three reasons the first reason is
even though in this class I keep on
saying there's no such thing as cultural
and genetic Purity the the the
icelanders come pretty close okay
there's about 3 330,000 people who live
in Iceland today and they're all related
to each other and that's because For the
Longest Time Iceland uh has been
isolated from the rest of the world and
it it has always been extremely peaceful
egalitarian and Progressive
Society they had the world's first uh
concept of parliament called the all
thing and that's where every um citizen
would come together once a year to
discuss the major political events um of
of Iceland so in other words they really
built they really built the Cornerstone
of modern European democracy but not
only that but a lot of the stories the
mythology
of the Vikings were reconceptualized and
written down in
Iceland and these sagas they're called
sagas okay would become the foundation
of modern European literature so the
cultural contribution of Iceland and the
uh wider Viking culture to the European
cultural framework it cannot be um
overstated okay
also they will make their way to the
British Isles um they will have ma major
encounters with the uh British people as
well as the Irish people they will found
a new city in irand called Dublin which
as you know is the mar capital of of
Ireland okay and as and what they will
also do is they will settle down in
Normandy and the reason why is they keep
on attacking northern Europe mainly the
coral legian Empire um and Charles
simple the king um of the Corian Empire
he will defeat them in a battle and then
he will give them land in Normandy so
Normandy means land of the Norse people
and then from normany as I mentioned
they will cross the English Channel and
Conquer England in the year 1066 at the
Battle of Hastings so if you look at
this map what you will discover
is the Vikings either founded or influen
four major European civilizations they
are Germany France Britain and Russia
now what's interesting is that for the
past 500 years these four nations were
the dominant militaries in the
world and not only that but they were
the dominant civiliz civilizations
in the world we think of modern Russian
civilization really we really mean these
four nations Britain France Germany and
Russia that's where the very best
literature philosophy and art uh comes
from and what I will show you next class
not this class but what I'll show you
next class is this is not just a
historical coincidence there are reasons
and factors that would uh that will help
us better explain why this happened
okay um this is the um settlement in New
Foundland okay so this was actually the
first European settlement in the New
World North America and this is 500
years at least 5 years before
Christopher
Columbus um this is a map that shows the
Viking expansion over time okay so as
you can see from this map they they they
basically expand
outwards and as they gather more
information about the world they
continue to expand okay so what is the
culture what is the mentality of the
worldview that drives this aggressive
expansion what is the Viking worldview
and this is something that I will
introduce this class but explain uh more
in detail next class
um so today when we think of the Vikings
we just think of Raiders and pillagers
but what's important for us to remember
is that the larger Viking culture most
people did not do that most people when
they engage with the uh European world
it was mainly through trade okay the
vast majority was through trade and
there were and there and then you have
people Vikings who um join the European
world as Mercenaries because they were
very good Fighters and then you you had
a small
minority who uh were Raiders and
pillagers but because they were so
violent they capture the imagination of
the Europeans and they inform um how we
today see the Vikings um this is a map
of the Viking expansion and the
yellow are written
records documented Viking rates in
Europe and as you can see there's a lot
of them okay they're mainly by the coast
they're mainly by Rivers because again
the Vikings raided mainly by using their
long ships their
ships um they mainly R
monasteries and uh to better understand
monasteries what they were imagine that
they are the equivalent of universities
they're basically the medieval
equivalent of universities these are
places where monks spent most of the
time um worshiping God by celebrating
his literary Works mainly the Bible
okay um the so the the monasteries were
built during something called the Kion
Renaissance and this marked the
beginning of the Holy Roman Empire
during this time there's a major major
Focus the major cultural Focus was on
producing books our modern ception of
the book actually comes from this period
they took all this sort of diverse
Innovation such as printing uh book
making uh fonts ink and combined to a
system of book binding that we still use
today okay so they mainly focus on uh
religious Classics like the Bible okay
and what they would do is they would
illustrate them it would take about 20
to 30 years for an individ ual monk to
create one of of these books so it was
it was a it was an artwork
basically um during this time they
experiment with they experiment with
different fonts if you go to your
computer and you ask Microsoft Word what
kind of font you want to use like Corgan
or others a lot of these fonts were
actually invented during this time
okay uh they also invented book binding
at this time as as
well and what they would
do um to mark their cultural achievement
is they would make covers of gold and
jewels diamonds sapphires
rubies um as a book cover all right so
these were extremely valuable unique
artwork this is another book cover okay
extremely gorgeous again they would
spent a lot of resources 20 30 years in
crafting each of these books and that's
why the Vikings raided them because the
Vikings knew through their trade
networks that the monasteries had this
contribution of wealth in them there's a
lot of gold and silver and jewelry in
monasteries and in Lan culture um these
precious metals were were a status
symbol they wanted them okay but you can
imagine what the Vikings did because the
Vikings were a
pagan non-literate people they didn't
understand books they have no use for
books so they they would come in and
they would take these books the Bible
rip out the pages and keep the gold and
then leave okay so you're a monk and you
see this right and it's the equivalent
of having your child killed before you
it was EX traumatic for them and again
the monks are litered people so they had
nothing nice to say about the Vikings in
fact they thought that the Vikings were
basically the equivalent of Satan okay
and and that's and that's why we have
such a Negative understanding of the
Vikings mainly through these raids which
again were only a minority of Viking
activity um during this
time um gradually over time what would
happen is that as the Vikings made more
wealth from monasteries W would spread
back to um the larger Viking culture and
more and more people would partake in
these raids until eventually they
develop the skill the Systems and
Technology to sack even cities like
Paris which was a heavily fortified City
okay and they would do this multiple
times um during the Viking age so what's
important for us to understand
is that this these Viking raids would
drive population growth in Scandinavia
and then this would drive
further uh Viking expansion throughout
the world okay so it was a
cycle um let's look at some cultural
aspects of the Vikings so this is these
are pictures of high status meaning
basically
Warriors um in
the uh Scandinavian culture and these
this is a picture of these Vikings uh in
the East they are called the Roose okay
the Roose and the Roose would would lend
would would become Russia okay so Russia
the country would borrow its name from
the the Vikings
Roose so some things some things to uh I
will point out about
um these visuals look at the helmets
okay the Vikings the popular depiction
of the Vikings is they had helmets of
horns right have you seen movies they do
not have horns guys because horns are
extremely un promatic impr practical
okay you might get stuck on on your boat
or or your enemy could Yank It Off you
okay so these were extremely
practical and UT turn people they were
not that wealthy that they to be very
careful and conscious about everything
they did okay so that's the first thing
second thing is that you will see major
cultural differences between Western
Vikings and Eastern Vikings and the
reason why is as the Vikings are um
interacting with different cultures
they're also assembling themselves into
different cultures they're intermarrying
they're adopting local languages and
local cultures and they're also Landing
their own culture to these cultures okay
so history is a continuous process of
cultural
integration all right and it's Dynamic
process it never really
ends Okay the third thing we need we
need to appreciate is these are a poor
people and as such they're extremely
egalitarian even though this these are
high status people they're not that
different from the majority of of
Vikings who are independent Farmers
basically
okay this is where they usually live
this is called long housee all right and
so because the weather in Scandinavia
it's very cold for most of the Year
these are a very social people they live
together they spend most of the time
together okay so this is a picture of a
Viking Hall um most of the time the
Vikings are together and they're usually
drinking and they're telling stories to
each
other
okay and so they're they're very much
focused on the oral
tradition let's look very quickly at
their longships which is the dominant uh
Maritime technology of the day okay
these are not that big but they're but
they are purposely designed to be small
so that they have
flexibility um and
maneuverability
okay um so this this is what we think
the ships look
like and this is what they really look
like um so some points we need to know
about the ships
is first of all from these ships you can
see that there's really no hierarchy in
place we don't know who the captain is
there's there's a captain but he's
really not that different from the
others okay so the Viking culture is
extremely egalitarian which is important
if you want um cohesion on the
battlefield these the Vikings rated for
gold but also for slaves okay so they're
trading with the wider world the Arabs
the byzantines uh the Chinese um they
what what they were trading were slaves
in exchange for silver which was very
important for their culture okay so they
were so they these were
slavers um the other thing to know about
these ships is they're not that big and
the reason why is they're usually
traversing Rivers when you when you're
traversing Rivers you need to be
flexible so some sometimes you might hit
some rocks well then what you have to do
is move that ship out of those rocks and
go somewhere else
okay all right so that's theide idea of
the long ships and again this was the
dominant Maritime technology of that
time the Europeans had absolutely no way
to counter
this okay um also what's important for
us to understand is the Vikings had also
many different designs so the thing
about the Viking ships is they're ex
extremely lean and mean they're
extremely efficient the only way you can
achieve the this efficiency is through
constant Innovation so the Vikings are
constantly always thinking about how to
better improve these
ships um the last thing I will mention
is the idea of the Viking
funeral now in cultures that we've
studied there's always a
spectacle that is the highlight of this
culture so uh the romance there
something called the triumph which was a
military parade to celebrate a general's
military victories overseas it was it it
was like the um biggest event in in the
life of a Roman okay so this would be
the equivalent of the Nobel Prize today
the Greeks had as equivalent of the
Triumph theater right um every Greek
wanted to be a playwright that was the
highlight of ethian cultural life what's
interesting for us is that for the
Vikings the spectacle that they they
cared the most about was a funeral okay
obviously not everyone would get an
elaborate
funeral only the chieftain or the great
warriors would get an elaborate funeral
but these funerals would take 10 days
and it would be very expensive basically
the entire Savings of this great warrior
would be invested in the funeral um
there there be a lot of sacrifices
mainly horse and animals humans be
sacrificed as well and the warrior the
king will be buried with a ship all
right so next class what I will do is go
into detail about these funeral explain
to you why they happen and their
cultural
significance all
right okay so that's an overview of the
Vikings what I will do now
is um explain the Vikings in the larger
historical framework that we've been
studying this semester but before I do
that are there any questions about the
Vikings
yes okay the slave trade right okay so
the slave trade it is just an in grow
interesting part of life in Europe at
this
time um the population was very limited
because Europe was a poor place and
there was very few agricultural Surplus
plus there was always these wars to be
fought okay so slavery was was just very
important um the people who really drove
the slave
trade um were the Banes the and the
Arabs and there's always demand from
these two cultural centers for slaves
which the Vikings provided now what's
interesting for us about the slave trade
is the Arabs are Muslim and the bises
are Christian and the consensus at that
time is you cannot enslave a fellow
believer so Arabs could not enslave
Muslims Christians could not enslave
fellow Christians that's why the Vikings
were so
that's why the Vikings found slave trade
so profitable because the Vikings were
pagans So in theory they could be sold
to
anyone okay so the Vikings basically um
enslaved other pagans and sold them to
both the byzantines and and the Arabs
okay and and look look um the slave
trade it it has been an integral part of
human interaction human trade for most
of civilization
okay does that make sense it's only it's
it's really only only until the British
Empire that we see a clamp down an
abolishment of the slave trade but and
also guys I mean I hate to say this but
slavery still happens it just happens
secretly we don't really pay much
attention to it but it still happens all
right okay great great question any more
questions before I I I
continue it's just a small question I
remember a long time ago this is
probably like 20 years ago um in Sweden
they discovered a few of the
Viking graes
from the ships were all that Y and at
that time the Swedish government decided
like this was too Sac we're not going to
we're going to keep it basically mysty
that's right since then do you know if
anything has changed has anyone conduct
these or yeah so um so so question then
is um we found in the like archaeologist
have found a lot of these ship burials a
lot of Graves and there's just a lot of
them and uh we we've we've had a chance
to study a lot of these Graves and here
are some interesting characteristics
about these Graves okay the first thing
is these graves are unique unto
themselves there doesn't seem to be a
system of bearing someone okay so you
have these Graves where um maybe a woman
is Beed with a horse then you have
another grave where a woman is bearded
with a ship that's the first really
interesting thing about these Graves
second thing is these Graves seem to
have a um a record of of lineage and and
what we mean by that is these people are
buried on top of their ancestors so um
uh if if a woman is buried here then
maybe her granddaughter would be buried
on top of her okay so there seems to be
a story going on um in these burials
Okay the third thing about these Graves
uh that we've discovered is that um
there there's been a lot of care and
attention paid to how someone was buried
okay clearly um someone put a lot of
thought or or the culture has put a lot
of thought into how this person will be
remembered all right and what I will
show you uh next class is what's
important is not the burial what's
important is the funeral the process of
the burial and that's where the culture
expresses itself and what I will show
you in next class is these burials
they're meant to send the dead into the
Afterlife okay and that's very important
what's really important important um and
why they have this pageantry or ritual
in the funeral process
is it's really about um memorizing that
person into the larger culture making
sure that everyone remembers the
contributions of that person and having
that person contribute eternally into
the overall culture okay if that makes
sense right but again as as as you know
most of these great have not been duck
up so right now we are making some
rudimentary guesses based on the
available
evidence
okay all
right any more questions before I
continue okay so so I know this is a lot
to take in but we are spending two
classes on this and hopefully uh this
will make more sense to you as we move
along okay all right good so let me um
discuss
the larger historical framework that
the Vikings are
in
okay so the major thesis of the semester
is the idea of the oceanic Oceanic
currents of
history and so one pattern that we see
in history
is a culture you know what call the
Borderlands they're isolated from most
of History okay um they're not
completely isolated but they're mainly
isolated and then what happens is that
an Empire a major civilization
expands so that it starts to interact
with uh this borderline culture and what
will happen for thisa action is the
energy of the Empire will start to
transfer to the Borderlands the
Borderland itself will expand okay and
until it comes into conflict with the
Empire and when this uh conflict happens
the Borderlands might be assimilated
into the Empire it might be destroyed by
the Empire or it might become the Empire
itself all right so that's the uh major
idea of this class and we see this
throughout history
okay so think of um the Greeks and the
Persians think of the Romans and the the
carthaginians think of the Arabs and the
um the Persians okay so we see this
pattern uh repeat itself throughout
history what I want to do now is apply
this idea to the Vikings and explain how
this process works why does this work
well if you think about it an Empire and
when I mean Empire I just mean large
civilization
um an Empire and a Borderland
culture they are almost um complete
opposites of each other they're
advantages um
miror they compensate for each other's
advantages and disadvantages so for an
Empire an Empire usually has three major
advantages they are Mass
organization and
death okay some historians use the word
strategic death
okay all right so what what do we mean
by this mass is a very simple idea it
just means a lot a lot of people okay
very simple idea second idea
organization means that there's a
hierarchy in place that allows the
Empire to organize its people in a way
that most benefits the Empire so for
example the Empire Can field large
armies and the idea of stratgic death is
that the Empire can actually afford to
lose a lot of battles and still continue
the fight so think about when Alexander
invaded
Persia he had already defeated the
Persians at the Battle of Isis but
Darius was able to go deeper into his
Empire and assemble another large army
for the Battle of guaga okay and Darius
could have could have when he lost that
battle he could have also built a third
Army But ultimately he was assassinated
by his by his generals on the other hand
Alexander the Macedonian he could not
have afford to lose one battle all right
if you think about the World War II
Japan had already conquered China's
entire Eastern Seaboard but the ging
dong under
changed refused to surrender and he
didn't have to surrender because he
could continue to go Inland right he
first went into Chongqing and then
chongu if he had to he would have gone
to kuming as well okay so that's the
idea of strategic death also um remember
in the history of Rome Hannibal had won
every single battle on the Italian
Peninsula he had destroy all Roman
armies but because of the idea of death
Rome did not have to surrender and Rome
only won one battle against Hannibal in
it in its history but that battle was
the only battle that really mattered it
was a battle of Z uh between cpio
africanist the Roman general and
Hannibal and Hannibal lost that battle
and so therefore Carthage lost a Second
Punic War okay that's the idea of death
that's the three major advantages of
Empire if you are a Borderland you have
none of these advantages okay but you
have three other advantages that
compensate for your weakness okay the
first is the idea of
energy so you have fewer people but
they're more energetic they're more
ambitious they're stronger they're more
aggressive overall second you don't have
um you don't have organization okay but
you have
openness the idea here is you are open
to new ideas and you can change as a
society at will and the reason why is we
said this when we talked about y okay
there's a very important principle that
drives Innovation it's called
open
Cooperative
competition that's why Thea were able to
innovate that's why the Greeks were able
to innovate open means there's no
Central Authority there's no
government Co Cooperative means that
you're separate but you're still
learning from each other competition
means you want to be better than your
neighbor okay and that's true for the
Vikings as as well and that's how they
were able to develop the ship technology
that enabled them to um pillage across
Europe okay so that's a main
advantage of the the Borderlands
okay does that make sense okay okay
so again the Borderlands have no death
they can be wiped up by an Empire very
quickly that's why the Borderlands are
opportunistic
this a very important idea just it just
it basically means the Borderland have
to be strategic in picking their fights
if you are bigger than me and stronger
than me I'll be your friend right but if
you're weaker than me then I will steal
from you that the idea here is
opportunistic you're Shameless in taking
advantage of those who you
can okay doesn't make sense so these are
the three major advantages of the
Borderlands and I want you to remember
this idea because it will repeat itself
over and over all right so let me um
very quickly
explain the idea of energy and mass and
for this let's do a thought experiment
okay let's pretend that you are 16y old
in Scandinavia and you're about
800 okay that's when the Viking age
Begins by by by age 16 what have you
learned what have you mastered well you
your family are basically independent
farmers who will engage in trade in
order to supplement um their income okay
so this is what you can do you can um uh
basically work the
farm work the farm basically means you
know how to grow your own food you know
how to cook your own food it means you
know how to to take care of animals if a
cow is about to give birth to a calf you
know how to do
so okay you know how to um save the life
of a
horse you know how to speak with a
horse okay you also engag in uh sea
trade
okay and the idea here
is is that you know how to cut wood and
from the wood build a boat and you know
how to we the stars and sail across
Europe
okay also you're a good fighter you're
able to wield an axe as a weapon you're
able to use a sword as a
weapon you're able to shoot an arrow
okay if I dropped you anywhere in
Scandinavia
you'll able to find your way home you'll
be you'll be able to fight wolves you
you'll be able to feed yourself in the
forest and you'll be able to find
yourself
home okay if I put you anywhere in the
European World you'll know how to
navigate yourself as to find yourself
home okay and so this builds the idea
that the Vikings at age 16 they're
extremely worldly people
okay they're
strong when I mean worldly I don't mean
Cosmopolitan what I mean is they have
Street smarts okay they're very strong
and they're very
resilient all right that's what a viking
teenager looks like now let's come back
to China in the present day and what do
you guys do what do you guys able to do
two things
okay memorize
useless
facts do stupid
tests okay I'm sorry to tell you the
truth but this is the truth okay you
throughout your education in China have
learned exactly two things memorize uses
facts and do stupid
tests all right and the reason why China
is like this the way the way that the
reason why most Mar societies are like
this is
they want to reduce your energy right
they want to be able to control you they
want you to fit into larger society does
that make sense so now you can see the
difference
between um an En energetic Society like
the Vikings and a mass like
China okay
um I am I'm I'll be very serious with
you I have three young kids my eldest is
seven my second one is almost four my
youngest is only
one as you know um I received a very
good education I was at Yale College for
my
undergraduate um and I've spent the past
20 30 years thinking deeply about
education and I'll be very honest with
you if I had a choice whether to send my
child to Yale or to Viking school I
would send my kid to Viking school
because I want my child to be worldly
strong and
resilient
okay all
right and yeah I'm not joking guys if
there if there were if there was s such
a thing as a viking school where you
learn to be a viking I would send my
kids to that school
unfortunately um there isn't okay let's
talk about let's talk about the idea of
opportunistic so the question that
Scholars have debated for a long time is
why the liking age start what prompted
the beginning of a Viking age why did
the Vikings go attack these monasteries
and there are different theories okay
the most popular theory is that as
Charlamagne and this Holy Roman Empire
um expand it it threatened Scandinavia
and so the Vikings had to come out and
challenge him okay that's the most
popular historical understanding and
then there's some other theories for
example population growth com change
internal conflict within Scandinavia
today I want to I want to explain a
different Theory to you which is just
that the Vikings were opportunistic an
opportunity arose that didn't exist
before and they took advantage of it
okay the opportunity are
monasteries after the collapse of the
Roman
Empire everyone believes that Europe
became a lot poorer okay and that's a
historical understanding but you think
about it what really happened is that
wealth became much more
distributed okay during the time of
Empire all wealth was being channeled
into certain
centers but we don't have an Empire then
farmers can keep the keep the wealth for
themselves so after the collapse of the
Roman Empire wealth was much more
distribute distributed but as these
kingdoms start to arise under
Charlamagne then wealth became much more
concentrated okay so these monasteries
they are universities they are places of
worship and of learning but much more
importantly they are places where wealth
is
concentrated okay concentration of
wealth these monasteries like Martin
universities are extremely
wealthy okay the first reason why
they're wealthy is their
Banks so the nobility was actually
storing the Surplus wealth meaning
silver and gold in these monasteries
these monasteries were considered to be
protected by divine power right no would
deer steal from a monastery monks are
extremely trustworthy so these
monasteries had a lot of gold and silver
stored and hidden within their
premises not only that but the
monasteries were are uh land owners so
they controlled up to 20% of local land
and of course what they would do is they
would take this land and lease it out to
Farmers and they made a lot of money
that
way um they themselves engage in their
own businesses for example um they had
their own breweries okay they could make
and sell alcohol and beer to locals also
as you can imagine because these are
religious centers
the locals would invest heavily in them
okay the locals would uh give them
treasures and as you can imagine because
there was this contition of wealth and
because monasteries were not protected
because they were considered protected
by God they made perfect places to
pillage right the Vikings knew about
these places and so these places were
perfect to pillage and that's what we
started the Viking age the fact that
weal was out being concentrated whereas
before it
wasn't all right so mon
stories then you had the idea of armored
Knights so the main
military
Innovation um in Europe at this time
were these tanks called armor knights
they were fantastic in battle that's how
charlam man was able to build the Holy
Roman Empire okay but you think about it
armor knites do not like water they will
drown in
water and so these Rivers were
completely
unprotected and the Vikings had these
long ships that were perfect for for
River
navigation okay so that that was another
opportunity that presented
itself the armor knights would give rise
to the idea of
feudalism feudalism just basically means
that these Arman knites became landowner
landowning Nobles that took advantage of
farmers so in order to get these Knights
to fight uh for them Kings would give
them land grants these Knights would
take this land and run it to Farmers
over time as we know farmers will incur
a lot of debt which me which means that
they will not become slaves to these
Nobles and this is the idea of
feudalism
okay
um and what this means is that by the
time the vi the Vikings
attacked Europe was becoming a very
hiero Society the thing about hieres is
they don't like to change so one
question historians had is well why
didn't the Europeans adapt themselves to
these Viking raids
some did okay but most didn't and the
reason why is if you change your
military tactic in order to respond to
liking threat you have to change your
hierarchy you have to change your
cultural hierarchy remember we we did
the Greeks we learned that depending on
your Society the structure of your
Society you had a different military
okay so if you were a Navy like Athens
you were democracy
if you had a Cavalry like the
macedonians you were a
monarchy if you had hop lights like the
Spartans you were an
oligarchy okay so the structure of your
military determine the structure of your
political
system so the Europeans purposely did
not respond to the liking threat because
they want to maintain their feudal
system okay and of of course this is
this is a very general statement a lot
did respond to liking threat but overall
they did not respond to liking threat
with the same emergency or sense sense
of anxiety um that they should
have the Viking age came to an end when
the Vikings amassed enough wealth to
align themselves with the European
nobility okay so the idea here is if
you're banded and you steal a lot of
money what what do you want to do you
want to become an aristocrat because
that's the best way to protect your
wealth right once you're an aristocrat
you your wealth becomes legitimate so
the Vikings um once they have mass
enough wealth the Europeans start to
into marry with them and the Vikings in
turn became Christians because that was
the best way to assimilate and as
Christians they would convert their own
followers and their own people as well
remember the spread of religion is
usually a topown process where you first
convert the convert the elite who then
convert the people it is not a bottomup
process
okay and also the Vikings provided
military um protection and support to
the European
powers okay and that's what ended the
Viking age the Vikings were so
successful that they were eventually
coopted into the European
nobility okay
so um um as I
mentioned the Vikings their culture
would heavily
influence um four new civilizations that
we will discuss later on the semester
and they are the British the English the
French the Germans and the
Russians okay and so what I what I will
do next class
is show you why Viking culture is so
influential
okay and to prepare for next class what
what I want to do
is give you a preview of how the Viking
worldview is very different from other
World Views
okay so um there's a
premodern understanding of the world and
there's a modern understanding of the
world okay so in the modern
understanding the world the world we
live in
today the
community is distinct from the
individual
okay the individual can be outside the
community okay that's why even though
you are Chinese you're still able to go
to America because you're you as an
individual ual can be separated from
your
community and often in the modern world
we believe that the community and
individual are in conflict with each
other so for example if you are a woman
historically you have been oppressed by
your community if you are homosexual the
same is true if you're a minority you're
often oppressed okay and that's and
that's what justifies the idea of the
nation
state the nation state
is a entity that protects the rights of
all individuals against the
community okay so that's a modern
conception of the
individual and we'll go into this later
on in the semester towards the end
because it's a very important concept
but first I want to introduce it to you
okay now
historically most cultures have not
believed this okay most cultures have
believed that the
individual can only exist within the
community
okay the community is that which gives
you history
tradition and a worldview a religion a
mythology and as your interpretation of
these things that allow for your
individuality but but you cannot exist
outside this tradition okay that's why
um most cultures the worst punishment
they inflicted on the individual was not
execution it was actually
banishment if you killed someone we
didn't kill you we banish you from the
community because that was considered
the worst possible
punishment to a person you cease to be
an individual you cease to be alive if
you're removed from the community that
gives you
nourishment
okay now but within this tradition
within within this understanding there
are different ways you could
conceptualize the idea of the community
and the individual okay so for example
let's look at the
Greeks the Greeks sorry um Let me let me
do this the
Greeks believe that the community
was a was the polus okay the polus and
that's where we get the word politics
from the polus is a place where people
Gather in order to discuss the political
Affairs of the
community okay that's what community was
it was where people came together to
discuss
politics and as a result the
individual is someone who stands out
okay that's why we have Concepts ER and
udonia in this community you are an
individual you are the best individual
if you can speak the best if you can
argue the best if you can stand
out okay so the prime purpose of Greek
life was to stand out so that you could
achieve yonia human flourishing as well
as achieve ER Human Excellence
that is
the um Greek understanding then you have
the
Romans the Romans Define community
as tradition and
history and
place as long as you are in
Rome and you believe in Roman history
and practice Roman tradition then you
are a Roman citizen
okay doesn't matter where you come from
as long as you're in Rome and you
practice Roman Traditions then you are a
Roman that's why for Romans what's
important is for the individual to be
Pious right individual is a Pious person
someone who is loyal to the Trad TR
sorry someone who is loyal to the
traditions
of Rome and who extends the traditions
of Rome through
Conquest that's why everyone wanted to
be a general like Julius Caesar to Eng
glory for Rome and that's how you show
piety to
Rome okay so we did the Greeks and the
Romans um now the
Vikings are very
different the Vikings are very different
people for them
community and the
individual are very different the
community is a collection of
stories all right the
community are stories that are told over
and over by the people inside the
community and as such the individual has
responsibility to add to the
story how do you add to the story
through
exploration through
Adventure through personal courage
that's why the
Vikings went off to settle Iceland and
Greenland that's why they pillaged these
monasteries in the South that's why they
went to the East and found settlements
like KF and novigrad and traded with a
wider world because they were trying to
add to the larger
stories of the Viking
community and that's and that's what's
important for them to be
remembered by the
community
Through adventure and
exploration okay that's a very different
concept and this is what I will explain
next class how the entire culture
revolved around this understanding of
the community and the
individual
right the last thing I will say is
what's really interesting uh for us is
remember that these three different
cultures are extremely different right
they have a very different approach to
the world but they all come from the
same cultural origin which is the Proto
indoeuropean culture
right what's interesting is that as they
came into Europe and they settled down
in different GE Geographic locations
interacted with different people they
adapted their culture
accordingly so the story of human
history is always one of innovation
change and
resilience okay
all right great any questions before I
conclude the
class was there anything you you not
you're not clear
about okay
okay so the idea of inter marriage okay
what's the idea of inter marriage
okay so what's really hard for us to
understand is that for most of human
history we didn't have a concept of race
culture ethnicity and borders and States
okay these are all modern Concepts that
we go that we use to
apply to history they're not very useful
so what I mean by that is the Vikings
didn't see themselves as in
culture they didn't think we're Vikings
we are not Greeks we're not Germans no
one saw themselves that way the
Germans broke the the G sorry the
Vikings their main political unit was
the village or the tribe right and the
way they fought Wars is these tribes
would join into temporary
confederations but these confederations
were extremely
fluid so if you're a tribe and you you
want to switch alliances you could do so
and no one could stop you okay so the
very idea of identity was extremely
fluid and what they understood was in
order to survive in the world you have
to build
alliances that means you build alliances
with other Vikings but if you could you
could you also want to build alliances
with the European nobility because they
have far more wealth technology and
resources than you do okay so when the
opportunity presented itself for them to
into Mary
into
um these um EUR into European nobility
and they did so okay so for example the
byzantines the Byzantine
Empire
was as we discussed a walled Empire so
it's impossible to invade and Conquer
okay the Europeans the Vikings couldn't
really conquer the B Empire but at the
same time because they were closed in
the Banes couldn't
really protect their empire so the only
way they could protect their empire was
not through the military but through
diplomacy through bribery through
intermarriages okay so the Vikings in
KF the byzantines made an offer we will
let you guys marry into the Empire okay
basically by having their ruler marry a
princess but on the condition of course
that you now serve the Empire and that
you uh converted Christianity Orthodox
Christianity right and as you can see
this makes sense for everyone the
byzantines now have uh more soldiers who
are proven and who have their own
territory and the nobility in KF like
basically the prince he now has
legitimacy right because he's also
fighting against the other Vikings in
the area okay does that make sense and
that's the idea of inner marriage to
form a political Alliance that benefits
you and and ultimately if you are a
ruler Prince you're always looking to
inter Mar as much as possible right
that's why these Kings had so many wives
these wives represent different
political alliances it wasn't because he
was really horny and he loved sex it was
because as a prince as a king you have
to have different alliances and the best
way to form an alliance was through
inter marriage and but if you if you
marry someone you must also marry into
her faith okay that was a
precondition and that's why uh the
Vikings in KF would convert to
Christianity the king converted and then
then the king wouldn't make his
followers convert but it's a process
that that would take Generations okay
these things are very slow because I as
I keep on saying this class mer uh
culture is
persistent right you do you understand
great great question okay any more
questions yep
okay so the question then is how like
were these premodern cultures these
Pagan culture uh t to an how do they
perceive gays and minorities well okay
um this is a propaganda from the nation
state okay this is what you're taught
today that we are a much higher
civilization because we're much more
tolerant towards minorities and the
truth of the matter is again when you
live in a culture which doesn't really
have boundaries and borders you're a
pretty open person so in the Pagan
culture there just is isn't the idea of
homosexuality men had sex with with each
other all the time and no one
cared okay and women um had fewer rights
but in the Viking culture women had
status okay often because they were uh
they practiced magic okay in their
culture men weren't allowed to practice
Magic Woman practice magic and as you
can imagine that would give woman
tremendous status okay okay so the idea
the idea that we have that Community
suppress the individual is something
that we believe we have faith in it but
it just is not historically true okay
also remember there's a fluidity Within
These communities so it's perfectly
possible for you to get up with your
family and move somewhere else no one
could stop you okay does that make
sense so the premodern world uh was much
more tolerant than the world we live in
today mainly because we not categorize
people back then okay so one thing that
we will learn um uh later on the
semester is that the the very idea of
race and racism it's a new modern
concept that didn't exist before we only
have this because of the idea of
imperialism right when you go and talk
other people you need to justify it
somehow the best way to do it is for
racism because they are an inferior race
and therefore we have come to civilize
them okay but this is only the past 20
years and before we didn't have a
concept of race all right great question
any more
questions fluid
y okay uh the Vikings okay um the
Vikings their worst punishment is
banishment as well so if you so for
example if you killed someone You' be
banished okay um the actual punishment
would be determined by a community
discussion but it was usually banishment
or exile for a number of years so in
Athens um you would be banished for at
most 10 years that was that was
considered like the most Grievous if you
commit the most Grievous crime
um then the worst punishment would be
banishment for like 10 years okay
because the understanding was that um
the worst thing that could happen to you
is banishment because again the
individual is part of the community you
uh were nourished by the community by
the community you were a nobody you were
basically a ghost or a zombie okay so
people man to come after years yes yes
they they always come back yes so the
Athenians banish a lot of people okay
and they always came
back and if if they if they're banished
they're always thinking about coming
back because again there was no idea of
the individual existing outside the
community you were the
community and if you came into a new
community then people just just assume
that you were a bad person and you were
ostracized because where's your
community man right because in the
ancient world the first question they
would always ask you is not what is your
name but where are you from right what
is your community because that's what
mattered not what is your name like what
do you like who are you it's always like
where are you from from what family from
what community from what Clan what tribe
are you from then we know how to
interact with
you
okay great great any more questions
great okay so next class we will do the
cultural system the cultural worldview
of the Vikings okay we'll take this
we'll take the idea of community
individual and expand it okay